salut marin c'est lui c'est dylan photo
de billy burke tu lui envoyer des photos
tac dont je suis pas un dégueulasse
c'était des photos de nixon c'est encore
pire qu'à québec et moi quelque chose
pour moi la première fois que tu es
budget voulait passé son bras autour de
ton cou
c'était une bonne première impression
kathleen était jolie les airs c'est pas
une raison pour exploser comme option
qu'est ce qui s'est passé kleenex com ou
non plutôt comme un ballon quoi
je pourrais récupérer brûler les
récupérer
les attendent quoi pour nous laisser
sortir mais sûr que ça se reproduira pas
que quoi se reproduira pas ça s'est
reproduit plein de fois non tout le
monde est oui les copains explose
vraiment je crois qu'on leur sert de
cobaye est déclinée battre identité
interrogé mon avocat et un autre amour
qui concerne ces biologistes qui me
plaît c'est vrai je te vois je suis trop
contente pas avoir explosé trop vite
ça
si aiguille a dit
[Musique]
le lycée est fermé maintenant vous
pourrez plus dire à mon époque les
choses étaient plus durs non tu as
raison
pour vous c'est pire